I think about food and categories I
think it's important that we eat a
balanced diet and that means lots of
fruits vegetables and whole grains
everybody knows that diets that are
based on those are associated with good
health and then meat and dairy if you
eat meat and dairy products you just
want to eat a lot of different kinds of
foods I don't think there's any one food
that anybody needs I can't think of a
single food that a single single food
that is absolutely essential if you look
at human diets across the entire world
you see the diets very enormous Lee and
depend on what's available locally so
the whole business about you need to eat
this food or you shouldn't eat that food
that's all about marketing it's not
about health
scientists have tried for decades to
find something wrong with caffeine and
they can't no matter how hard they try
we metabolize caffeine
some of us metabolize it better than
others I happen to be a fast metabolizer
so it doesn't affect me at all unless I
have really a lot of it but for people
who are sensitive to caffeine they know
it they know that if they eat something
that's got caffeine in it they get jumpy
and shaky and they don't like the way it
feels so they cut back on it but if
you're not really consuming huge
quantities it doesn't have very much of
an effect I don't think it's so good for
kids and certainly teachers in school
complain a lot that if the kids are
highly caffeinated they're bouncing off
the walls and it makes it harder for the
kids to concentrate and harder for them
to do their work so that would be the
main thing but what really bothers me
about it is it's not labeled I think it
ought to be labeled on food products and
on drinks so and then people have a
choice right now they don't have a
choice
energy and food comes from protein fat
and carbohydrate any food with protein
fat or carbohydrate will give you energy
you want fast energy than that's
carbohydrates rapidly absorbable
carbohydrates or sugars but all foods
give you energy that's what calories
about are about that's why you have to
eat if you need energy and the nutrients
that go with it
there's way too much salt in American
diets even people who aren't susceptible
to hypertension are getting too much
salt and there's so much evidence that
salt is related to high blood pressure
and high blood pressure is related to a
whole host of chronic diseases coronary
heart disease stroke and so forth it
would be really terrific if we could cut
down on our salt intake
we don't need nearly as much as we're
eating and the real problem with it is
that nearly 80% of the salt in American
diets is there before anybody has any
choice about it it's either in the
processed food that we buy in the store
or it's in the restaurant food or the
food the pre-prepared meals that are
outside the amount that's added at the
table is minimal compared to what's
already there so what that means is that
for somebody who wants to cut down on
salt you can't eat processed foods and
you can't eat restaurant foods we need
to do something about that at the policy
level so that restaurants and processed
foods will cut down on the soul and make
it easier for people to eat less
there's way too much salt in American
diets even people who aren't susceptible
to hypertension are getting too much
salt and there's so much evidence that
salt is related to high blood pressure
and high blood pressure is related to a
whole host of chronic diseases coronary
heart disease stroke and so forth it
would be really terrific if we could cut
down on our salt intake
we don't need nearly as much as we're
eating and the real problem with it is
that nearly 80% of the salt in American
diets is there before anybody has any
choice about it it's either in the
processed food that we buy in the store
or it's in the restaurant food or the
food the pre-prepared meals that are
outside the amount that's added at the
table is minimal compared to what's
already there so what that means is that
for somebody who wants to cut down on
salt you can't eat processed foods and
you can't eat restaurant foods we need
to do something about that at the policy
level so that restaurants and processed
foods will cut down on the soul and make
it easier for people to eat less
there's a lot going on in government
right now trying to work with food
manufacturers and restaurants to cut
down New York City for example has a
very quiet under-the-table initiative to
try to get the salt and you see the
problem with salt is that if you're
eating a lot of it you don't notice the
taste of it
you only notice the taste of it if
you're not eating a lot of it and so if
everybody in the population was eating
less then the foods that are out there
would taste terribly salty but unless
all of the food manufacturers and all of
the restaurants cut down at the same
time then nobody wants to go first so
that's really what the problem is that's
why you need government intervention in
this to try to make it easier for people
to cut down on their salt intake because
even if you want to it's really hard
organic and in the United States has a
very precise meaning it's what the
Department of Agriculture defines it as
and it defines it very precisely for
plants as no genetic engineering no
irradiation no fertilization with sewage
sludge no chemical fertilizers or any of
those kinds of things it's very precise
definition of what can and cannot go
into a food that is called organic with
that but the animals the definition is
also quite precise the animals have to
be raised on organic feed they have to
have access to the outdoors they can't
be treated with antibiotics or hormones
and so for this the rules are very long
and to the and those in the places that
produce those organic animals or plants
are inspected to make sure that they're
following the rules so that's that
system and to the extent that it works
it works pretty well most people think
it works pretty well and there's not an
enormous amount of cheating going on
because of the inspection system and
because the organic producers know what
the other ones are doing and so they
turn each other in if there's a problem
there's not a lot of cheating going on
but with that said a lot of people feel
that the organic rules are not strong
enough that they really don't deal in
particular with the ability of animals
to be outdoors just because they have
access to the outdoors doesn't mean they
are actually afterwards that's a big
loophole and also there's no requirement
for sustainability so you can have
industrial organic agriculture that is
just as devastating to land sea and air
and climate as industrial anything else
and that's I think a problem I think the
Department of Agriculture is looking at
ways to strengthen the organic rules and
ways to make sure that they're kept
honest
pets are in many ways just like people
just like people can eat lots of
different kinds of diets and they're
perfectly healthy diets you know I mean
think about the difference between
Mediterranean and Asian diets for
example they're really different and yet
people can thrive on it the same thing
is true of cats and dogs you can feed
them a lot of different kinds of foods
and they'll do just fine
what you need to make sure that they're
getting all their vitamins and minerals
and that the calcium and phosphate
balance is appropriate for bones but
beyond that you want to feed pets a
varied diet in the same way that you
want to feed yourself a very diet and if
you're eating a healthy diet a really
healthy diet you can feed your pet what
you're eating
if you think about it for a minute
that's how those animals were eating
well cats I guess were out hunting but
dogs the way that dogs got no tamed and
they descended from wolves over
thousands and thousands of years but
everybody thinks that the way that
happened was that they started hanging
around garbage dumps you know and if
you've had a dog you know one of those
dogs that isn't finicky you know dogs
will eat anything
oh no I mean they were carnivores
originally they descended from
carnivorous wolves so they do just fine
with me you don't want to give him bones
unless you're watching them very
carefully because the bones can shatter
and do bad things but you wanna be
careful about the bones
yeah school lunches are promoting
childhood obesity but in an indirect way
they said whatever goes on in school
sets an example for kids about what's
supposed to be and if the kids are being
fed chicken fingers and salty foods and
sweet things and and I have a lot of
sweet and salty snacks around that
they're eating they think that's
appropriate and that's the school saying
this is what you're supposed to be
eating and that's why I think it's so
important to have school lunches that
serve healthy food and I've been to
schools that do and they're very
impressive guess what the kids eat it
seemed perfectly happy
yeah and there are two things that have
to happen one is the government has to
set rules for what kids can and cannot
eat in schools so that you know the
rules are in place and then you need
people in the schools who really care
about wanting to do a good job of
feeding kids and think it's really
important for kids eat healthfully in
schools where that's happening the food
is good the kids are eating it
everybody's happy
I think it's that a healthy diets have
small amounts of me there's you can be a
vegetarian and be perfectly healthy and
vegetarians in general or healthier than
people who eat a lot of meat but there
are advantages to eating small amounts
of meat there are they're not necessary
advantages but they're there and
certainly in developing countries where
kids don't have enough food a little
meat thrown in makes a big nutritional
difference in the United States where
there's plenty of food around I don't
think it makes very much difference the
only thing that vegetarians need to
worry about is eating a variety of food
and getting enough calories which is not
very hard to do I don't see vegetarian
diets as being an issue in any way
whatsoever as long as there's some
animal food in the diet like eggs or
fish or dairy products or something like
that
the minute you move from that into vegan
diets you raise questions about one
vitamin and that's vitamin b12 because
that only comes from products of animal
origin or bacterially fermented foods so
you have to make sure that you've got a
source of vitamin b12 in your diet and
that you're eating a variety of foods
but other than that I just don't see it
as an issue at all except for kids for
small children and sometimes hard for
children to get enough calories unless
they're getting enough fat in with the
vegan diets that they're getting but
parents vegan parents know how to deal
with that most of them and do a pretty
good job and the kids are healthy it's
fine I said I kind of see all that as a
non-issue and I'm surprised at the
passion about it on both sides I still
hear from people about how dangerous
vegetarian diets are which seems kind of
silly and on the other hand I hear from
vegetarians and vegans about how
terrible it is to eat meat and I don't
buy either one of those
yeah the issue of meat-eating and the
environment is a very important one
particularly industrially industrially
raised meat in confined animal feeding
operations where you have large number
of animals in a very small area and
there's the whole question of first of
all what happens to their waste because
a pig farm can easily produce the amount
of waste that a city of 20,000 people
would produce in a day and yet it's not
treated no human population of 20,000
would be allowed to produce waste that
wasn't treated to destroy pathogenic
bacteria and yet we have laws that allow
these places to pollute the environment
with animal waste I think that's huge
problem and you go to a place that's
near a pig farm and you know about that
pig farm miles away you can smell it
that's something that we need to do
something about and I don't think that
CAFO should be allowed to leave their
waste untreated there there are other
issues that have to do with greenhouse
gases and the fact that so much of our
grain corn soybeans and corn and
soybeans particularly is grown expressly
to feed animals if we didn't have if we
didn't need so much meat then we
wouldn't need to grow all that food to
feed animals and that would also have
great benefits for the environment so I
guess where I stand on this is if you do
eat meat then just don't eat so much of
it